اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من رفح اهلا بكم بن
كفير يدعو مجددا لتشجيع سكان غزه على
الهجره ويتهم اداره بايدن بعرق المجهود
الحربي الاسرائيلي ويقول ان نتنياهو على
مفترق طرق وان عليه الاختيار من جانبه
طالب جانس نتنياهو بكبح جماح بن كفير ووقف
اضراره بعلاقات اسرائيل الاستراتيجيه في
حين اكد لبيد ان تصريحات بنكبر دليل على
لعدم سيطره نتنياهو على المتطرفين في
حكومته وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه لحرب
غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل جندي خلال
العمليات جنوبي القطاع والقسام تقصف
تجمعات لقوات الاحتلال في مدينه غزه وتدمر
دبابات في خانيونس في حين طالب ضباط
بارزون بالجيش الاسرائيلي رئيس الاركان
بوقف حمله التشهير بالانر لانها قد تقود
الى وضع اشد خصوه مع استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه على مواقع في وسط وشرق مدينه
غزه وزاره الصحه تعلن استشهاد
127 شخصا في القطاع في 14 مجزره نفذها
الاحتلال خلال يوم واحد وقصف مدفعي وسط
وغرب خانيونس جنوبي القطاع تزامنا مع
اشتباكات بين المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال قصف
امريكي بريطاني يستهدف مناطق عده في اليمن
واشنطن تقول ان الضربات تهدف الى تقليص
قدره الحوثيين على مهاجمه السفن ولندن
تشدد على ان هدف الغارات حمايه حريه الملع
من جانبها اكدت جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
مواصله العمليات حتى وقف الحرب على غزه في
حين قالت طهران ان الهجمات تتناقض مع
ادعاءات واشنطن ولندن بشان عدم اتساع نطاق
الحرب الى
اللقاء